c'est un projet d'envergure auquel se
préparent la ville de plaisir la
requalification de son centre ville
trois secteurs sont particulièrement
concernés le quartier du val hibou la
zone de l'hôpital charcot et le centre
historique
une évolution conséquente pour les
plaisirs oies et c'est justement avec
eux que la mairie soit travaillée elle a
organisé trois réunions publiques
destinées aux habitants
moi je suis plus intéressé par la
refonte les le projet du centre ville
sur le site de l'hôpital charcot donc
comme j'habite juste en face donc jusqu
aux premières loges donc s'il ya des
maisons des immeubles qui vont être
construits ça m'intéresse au plus haut
point bas à savoir jusqu'où cet
aménagement va aller au niveau de cette
ville
comment ça va se passer des
interrogations nombreuses même si
l'heure est toujours à la concertation
je crois qu'il ya encore des personnes
qui pensent que ce sont déjà des
résultats et des décisions que nous
avons prises alors que non nous ne
sommes que dans une phase diagnostic
on est dans une dans une discussion dans
un échange pour vous justement
imaginez ce qu'on pourrait faire 6 sur
la ville il y avait des choses qui
allaient se libérer
parce que la fusion des deux hôpitaux
fait qu' il y a beaucoup de foncier qui
se libèrent actuellement et on va pas
laisser faire n'importe quoi parmi les
pistes évoquées
l'aménagement du ru le prolongement
d'une coulée verte et la création de
liaisons douces
concernant le vélib ou la réhabilitation
a déjà commencé pour casser
l'enfermement du quartier de la ville
prévoit de nouveaux cheminements et la
création d'une place avec différents
commerces
il ya plusieurs coulées vertes ya
plusieurs il ya la coulée bleus et puis
il ya également toute cette installation
des pistes cyclables que ne souhaitant
mettre d'agrandir les trottoirs et puis
aussi de remettre et de repositionner
les commerces de proximité on a la
chance d'avoir une zone commerciale très
intense mais il faut aussi que l'on
maintienne et que l'on développe tout
cet espace qui est l'espace des
commerces de proximité
favoriser les petits commerces une
demande des habitants
elle concerne également le centre
historique un projet important qui
devrait se concrétiser d'ici 20 à 25 ans
les plaisirs oies sont toujours invités
à laisser leurs avis et leurs questions
sur le site plaisir demain point com